maradona did not die
he was killed chanted hundreds of his
followers in the center of buenos aires
maradona's daughters attended the rally
and joined his fans
in the call for justice
his entourage used him were with him for
money
they let him die they gave him weed beer
if you love someone you don't do that
they have to pay
if it's not in jail there has to be
social condemnation
[Applause]
people blocked one of the main avenues
of argentina's capital
they want a full investigation into what
happened to their idols
maradona was a god-like figure in
argentina who struggled with alcohol and
drug
abuse he had a poor health but still the
ministry of justice in argentina
appointed
a medical committee to investigate
maradona's death
it is expected to take two to three
weeks to issue its findings
a documentary by infowai a local media
company
revealed audio recordings said to be
between maradona's lawyers
doctors and caretakers in them
prosecutors
say there is enough evidence to
prosecute maradona's doctor
and six others the documentary reveals
how his daughters wanted to hospitalize
him after his brain surgery
but it's alleged his entourage wanted to
take him to a private home
so they wouldn't lose control over him
and the profits he generated
but what we expect is that the
detectives can have access to all of the
documentation that the public prosecutor
has been gathering very meticulously to
reconstruct this great puzzle
that is the events at the end of diego
armando maradona's life
so what we expect is that each of the
detectives
will issue an expert opinion one of his
biographers says
what's happening is a legal battle
i feel it's a battle between lawyers
between his descendants
diego at heart problems lung problems
addictions
all sorts of problems what's
extraordinary is that he made until he
was 60 years old
maradona was a man who generated passion
when he was alive
and continues to do so now that he is
dead
buenos aires